as you may know Donald Trump's daughter
Ivanka Trump can't have a formal role in
her dad's administration because of
anti-nepotism laws and there's a law
known to some as the bobby kennedy law
which went into effect six years after
John F Kennedy made his brother Robert F
Kennedy the US Attorney General in 1961
and there's debate over whether this is
directly related to that appointment or
whether it was actually about nepotism
it's smaller post offices and Congress
and elsewhere it doesn't really matter
it's the law today but Ivanka Trump
regardless is going to be getting an
office in the White House and playing
more and more of a role in Donald Trump
administration how is this legal you
might ask well she's not going to have a
formal role nor is she going to have a
government salary nor is she going to be
a government employee Ivanka Trump is in
the process of getting a security
clearance according to Politico
something that during the transition
period created tons of controversy and
was then denied as untrue well now she
actually is going to be getting a
security clearance she's going to be
receiving a government-issued
communications device this week she's
basically going to be a staff member of
her father's administration in
everything but the name she's not going
to have to be sworn in as a result she
won't have an official position she
won't be receiving a salary according to
her attorney I would argue Pat that this
is actually even sketchier than just
giving her a job so Trump can't just
give her a job because of anti-nepotism
laws laws that make sense
but this is actually sketchier because
he's found a way to circumvent the
spirit of the law by not giving her a
salary and not making her an official
employee but she's going to be involved
in any number of important ways in the
administration of her father and the
thing is you can be opposed to these
anti-nepotism laws they actually think
Bobby Kennedy was a fantastic Attorney
General particularly on the issue of
civil rights but you have to be able to
pass an act through Congress and change
the law they were able to do that for
general mattis instead of having a quota
that you had to be out of the military
for seven years they reduce that down to
four right so the change could happen
but if you try to skirt the law in some
way that
just not legal absolutely and we've seen
Ivanka Trump's involvement almost since
day one of the transition phase you'll
remember Ivanka Trump showing up in
pictures with Japanese diplomats she was
seated next to the German Chancellor
Angela Merkel during her her first
official visit to the White House which
by the way completely imploded in
hilarious embarrassment as I told you
about yesterday
and obviously ethics watchdogs saw this
and immediately said yeah it's not clear
that this setup is going to avoid
conflicts of interest the most
understated possible reaction you could
have to this this is a nepotism period
it almost sounds like a joke when I read
about this I thought oh this must be a
satirical story it's not and can you
imagine for a second Pat the right-wing
outraged if Hillary Clinton had won and
Chelsea Clinton was going to do the
exact same thing Ivanka is doing here it
would have an outrage it would have been
the new Benghazi email scandal yeah but
this story just doesn't even register
with everything else that's going on I
wonder too if Trump will have a tough
time getting her next job because she
can't even put this on a resume she
doesn't have a job title yeah it's going
to be completely useless to her and her
ability to generate generate income in
the future right I'm sure discuss this
with us on reddit I think there is
already a discussion thread there about
this if not we should create one david
pakman.com slash our EDD IT today's
episode of the david pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like an an
eyeglass or the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high
even over $300 for prescription glasses
with Warby Parker they started just 95
bucks mine cost that including lenses
and for every pair sold they give a pair
to someone in need so to try the five
pairs and support the David Pakman show
go to Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS